[Music]
joe biden's win
may be a double-edged sword for teacher
unions teacher unions worked hard to
elect biden
a long-time ally and public support for
teachers is high
many parents express a newfound
appreciation for just how exhausting the
job can be
yet as school systems around the country
shut their doors
or delay reopening despite mounting
evidence that in-person learning can be
done safely
parents patience is wearing thin until
now
president trump's reckless calls for
schools to open immediately
have allowed unions to portray their
resistance to reopening
as the responsible position with trump
gone
that changes if biden is wearing a mask
and pushing for more school funds
it'll be tough for unions to insist that
reopening is just a trumpian rush
back to business as usual under
president biden unions will face a clear
choice
help lead on responsibly reopening
schools or risks stoking concerns
that they're more focused on member
convenience than student well-being
their choice will be telling
do you think teachers in schools have
risen to the challenge of covid
let us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei